magna gate don't let them through give
us the stick humans suck you dry up come
again but God does think of truth while
we defend the fortress i-i-i-i we're not
playing pirates inside do you love Eric
Cartman's aggressive profanity do you
know more than you should about Randy
Marsh's masturbation addiction does the
term anal beads make you giggle if so
you'll enjoy the 11 or 12 hours of gross
humor South Park the stick of truth
gives you this is a game that features
more farting than a chili cook-off and
more anus humor than a proctologists
appointment book this is also the
closest there's ever been to an
interactive South Park film you get a
free wish just keep your expectations in
check if it weren't for the sight of a
grown man engaged in gentle coitus with
a farm animal the stick of truth might
have been called baby's first RPG it's
so easy that you can coast through on
medium difficulty without activating
your brain and it's more shallow than
Ike's baby pool well 11 hours might be a
lot of time to spend listening to
abortion jokes we're role-playing games
are concerned that's pretty short from a
gameplay perspective they're simply not
a lot to it the stick of truth is fun
however in a I just farted on a nazi
zombie fetus kind of way you take the
role of the new kid in town and head out
to make friends with kyle mr. slave
jesus and the rest of the gang there's a
mystery plot involving Taco Bell and
alien invasion and other store related
blather but that's all beside the point
the stick of truth story is a joke
delivery mechanism Cartman bestows
titles on you like sir douchebag and
commander douchebag audio logs make fun
of audio logs you throw lots of poop and
to space antennae snakes out of your
butt
by the time you reach the disturbing
abortion minigame you'll have already
figured out if the stick of truth
tickles your funny bone or makes you
weep for our world's future and so you
hobble about the town as a customizable
cardboard cutout as either a fighter a
mage a thief or a Jew do you have so I
guess we'll never really be friends
your choice determines your special
abilities in the game's turn-based
battles if you're a Jew for instance you
can throw stones at enemies using slang
of David and use circumcised to inflict
bleeding damage to their man's hearts
don't get too hung up on your choice of
class however while your assigns default
gear and occasionally earn new class
specific gear you can wear any armor and
wield any weapon you find or purchase
you can further customize your weapons
with strap-ons and your armor with
patches but these options don't deepen
the game just equip the highest level
stuff you have pop in whatever upgrades
sound fun and you're good to go the cash
pours in quickly and there are so many
recovery items like health potions
scattered around that you run out of
room for these items faster than you can
use them in fact stick of truth' is so
easy and simple that you'll likely
forget you even collected some of the
stuff the most valuable combat items
aren't the most effective but rather the
most entertaining to unleash throwing
turds may not be the most effective
tactic every time but watching bullies
barf is too fun of a possibility to pass
up the mechanics of these battles are
utterly simplistic you and one other
party member take turns hammering on
hall monitors and hobos until they keel
over there are some peripheral
considerations like summons power points
and mana but there's not a lot to any of
this there are two major reasons to stay
fully conscious during combat firstly
battles capture the essence of the show
it's almost impossible not to laugh when
jimmy buffs you by singing a magical
about your mom
I glanced that she said of all the
maiden from Stone Barry who is also your
mum secondly almost every attack
requires some kind of interaction
sometimes in the form of a well-timed
button tap sometimes in the form of a
twirl of the thumb stick and sometimes
in the form of a dance dance revelution
type minigame your minds may not be
fully engaged but at least your fingers
are busy my god that was some skills
allow you to avoid combat entirely
though these opportunities are heavily
scripted so don't go thinking you'll
suddenly have a wealth of new options
when you unlock new fart attacks indeed
if you were to remove the license the
stick of truth shallowness would be
achingly apparent with a journey to the
great nation of Canada standing out as
the game's most interesting sequence but
the stick of truth cannot be separated
from its license and it's in its vulgar
attitude that it finds redemption this
is not the second coming of role-playing
games but you'll still find Jesus one
way or another
lock and load
you